one
eternal infinite dreamer
that is what we are
all of these creation designs
are dreams just like
when we go to sleep at night
which we spend a third of our lives
sleeping
and we dream a simulated environment
and we dream the observer
and we're in that dreamed environment
we're enjoying
the eiffel tower we're enjoying a
relationship we're enjoying an
experience we're enjoying some food
all of what we're enjoying is completely
dreamed
all of what we're experiencing is
completely dreamed
the experiencer is dreamed and the
experience
is dreamed the environment is dreamed
all is dreams
as above so below similarly to when we
dream at night
this reality is just like
that one eternal
infinite dreamer we are that
we are the dreamed observers
that are immersed into the realities
that are experiencing the realities
all worlds all
combinations that are possible
this is but one combination this
specific
earth orbiting this specific star
93 million miles away
four billion or so years of evolutionary
history
a couple million years evolved from
chimps
all of the civilizational advancements
that have happened in the last couple
thousand years
all of the history that we have the
conflict
the prosperity our unique little story
and narrative
a hundred billion humans having lived
and died before
us today
this little story of this specific
world and where we're going everything
happening around
artificial general intelligence
everything happening around
cryptocurrencies and decentralization
and neuralink and biotechnology
all of that is its own unique expression
of infinity
its own unique dreamed world
and this is but one of those expressions
when we use our imagination we bring
ourselves
out of the box to all of the
other creative explorations that are
simultaneously happening
today when i was reading i am that by
nisargata
maharaja outside in the backyard
this hummingbird came over and
was just
in taking some of the nectar on some
nearby flowers
and i watch these hummingbirds all the
time and i've been
adamant about benoit mandelbrot in the
in
infinite fractal zoom and i've always
been wondering how to communicate more
effectively the
the speed at which these universes are
created
and i finally figured out that a really
good way to explain it is that universes
birth and die at the same
speed that a hummingbird
bats its wings
that's the imagination that we have to
use
to imagine all of the other
creation designs that exist
along with ours we're very hubristic
we're very overly self-confident
we're very myopic we believe
that our creation design
is all that exists or even worse our
perspective
is all that exists my egoic contracted
finite biological entity that is seeking
happiness and peace
externally is all that exists that's the
absolute worst
now in the non-dual tradition of course
everything is already whole
and complete and perfect and yet at the
same time in the duelist the concession
that egoic contracted energy
that is seeking peace and happiness
externally that can't even get outside
of its
own perspective
and try and take in a second or third
perspective of the same
consciousness that it's a part of but it
doesn't yet know that
that that is ignorance that is
intoxication by maya
and liberation and knowledge becoming a
gnostic
being is the turn inward to recognize
one's own infinitude and the infinitude
of all of these creation designs
and how we are the eternal shared
awareness
the analogy that works the best that's
very childlike
the pupil the pupil is the eternal
shared awareness
and the iris is the unique
coloration of that expression of
infinity
so you are a unique expression of
infinity
you have your own unique contribution
in this dreamed creation design and yet
the shared eternal observer witness
i am-ness that
is the pupil
that is what is the constant
the immovable that is constantly
experiencing
the different dreamed creation designs
that's what's been happening that's
what's going to keep happening that's
what eternal
infinite dreamer means
and you take yourself also to all of the
experiences that are happening again
if you bring yourself outside of
just the limited finite perspective that
you have
and you're just in a sp
place where you can undergo the process
earlier today i'm out
sitting on one of the nearby popular
streets here
in los angeles and
i'm watching a group of six
people at a table interact with one
another
i'm recognizing that i am the awareness
that is also the awareness that is
in all of those
expressions of infinity that are talking
to one another
so i'm simultaneously holding my
own awareness while i also expand
my awareness to
the observation and the witnessing of
the six that are communicating with one
another
these are really important advancements
to make in your all-inclusive
awareness becoming more non-personal
becoming more god-realized
becoming more of infinity
the one infinite creator
that is undergoing the process of being
able to
take your perspective and expand it out
to all
of the observation that's happening the
all-inclusive awareness that's happening
across all of the dream creation designs
not just this stream creation design
and not just the six people talking
there
at the table let alone just
your observation
so again you're going from your
observation expanding it outward to
being able to
undergo the process of holding all
of the six observations that are
happening and interacting with another
at that table
to what about all of los angeles what
about
all eight billion people on the planet
can you hold
the all-inclusive awareness of all eight
billion
observations that are happening
all eight billion unique expressions of
infinity
and the more that you refine that
ability
the more that you god realize that is
what is called the repetitions
you are going to be doing these
workouts these repetitions
and the more that you do them faster
at younger ages the more you gain
compound
interest of enlightenment downstream
that's why so much of the indigenous
cultures around the planet
are focused on not even allowing
the egoic contracted finite
energy to even form upon
birth only modernity
and ignorant parenting allows
the egoic contracted finite energy to
form
conscious parents enlightened parents
assist in the process to where from the
infancy
that the child comes into the world as a
gnostic
being it knows itself as the one eternal
infinite dreamer and knows its eternal
shared awareness and it knows itself
as an expression a unique artistic
expression of that
infinitude
that's our future of an enlightened
civilization
and so we're holding as much of this
all-inclusive awareness as possible
we're doing the repetitions
that enable us to recognize that
at a deeper and more profound level
every single day we're going through the
process
and that's what also brings peace and
happiness and
awe
as buddha was so adamant about
when you get to these states of being
you no longer
experience anger and frustration
and misery craving and aversion
you're not attached to the clouds
you recognize yourself as the sky that
eternal shared awareness
and even further you recognize that even
the eternal shared awareness is a
dreamed
agent of what is an agent less
absolute
why are we doing this what's up with
this one
eternal infinite dreamer
the word leela in sanskrit the divine
play the cosmic play
that's what it means to be eternal
that's what it means to be
infinite there is no beginning
there is no end
that's why in the radical non-duality
it is said that you are already whole
this is already complete this appearance
expand yourself out into the time scales
of billions or trillions of years
there were creation designs before this
that we dreamed there are going to be
creation designs
after this that we dream this is but
one appearance
so love yourself and accept yourself
first and foremost the direct path to
peace and happiness
quiet the mind as patanjali
said in the yoga sutras
union yoga with the absolute with god
is the quieting of the waves of
consciousness
and then the recognition of that eternal
shared
awareness begins to shine
we recognize we are the sky that has the
modulations of clouds that appear
in that observation in that witnessing
and then we recognize that even that
agent of awareness is dreamed
and that's the last thorn and that's
that absolute realization
all of it is leela all of it is the
divine
cosmic play
bring yourself back to being a child
having that aw
very similar to what entheogens do
anthogens loosen the grip
neuroscientifically on that
default mode network enabling
all of these novel connections to happen
across
neural networks the ah
resumes the creativity is enhanced why
so many elites around the world
undergo these microdoses of entheogens
bring yourself back to that childlike
neuroplasticity bring yourself
back to when you have that awe
and what happens is you recognize the
dance
you recognize the singing
you recognize the creating you recognize
the play
of what this is every single note
is play
every single note is the divine symphony
and to ride like david hawkins said
right on the crest of every
single one of the waves
every one of those notes
to re baseline ourselves
so that we don't have that aversion or
the craving
like buddha taught to eradicate that
suffering
to have that equanimity to recognize the
diamond necklace that's already around
our necks
like rumi said
and we bring that peace happiness and
awe
to the dreamed creation design rather
than trying to
extract it from the creation design
as rupert spyra said
it's the divine play the cosmic play
the singing the dancing the creativity
the iris that is unique around
every single one of our eyes is the
creative
contribution the creative expression of
infinity that we
are here in this creation design
it's unbelievably beautiful it's
unbelievably perfect it's indescribably
perfect it's ineffably perfect
as the sufi metaphysic goes only
those that are truly ignorant seek what
is already there
yet it remains for you to recognize it
this is what is important that
much of the neo-advaita
and the non-dual will not
make clear when you say
that there's nothing to seek
to also say that yet it remains for you
to recognize it this is
over a thousand years old from the sufi
metaphysics
it remains for you to recognize that
diamond necklace of the eternal
shared awareness that is dreamed
and that's why there is
the conceptual
frameworks that enable
more and more of the recognition to
truly sit in the heart
when you've actually dived into
theravada buddhism and
sat at a 10-day silent meditation
retreat
when you've actually read the daodaching
when you've actually underwent a heroic
dose
of magic mushrooms when you've went
through the processes
it makes it so that when you undergo the
satori
going through this surveillance veil or
this gateless gate
what happens is that you feel it
in your heart that that awareness is
eternal and
shared that these creation designs are
dreamed there is no longer
any tendency for anger for misery for
frustration for craving for aversion
but in order to eradicate the suffering
at those deepest roots
it really requires surgery
and that's why buddha taught via the
breath
this tool that's always with us
leverage the breath to quiet the mind
and then all of those other steps will
open up flawlessly
the perennial wisdom across the mystic
traditions
is very clear about silence
the very silence between the notes is
what
makes the symphonic so
beautiful
the very silence between the words
is what enables our communication
with no silence between the words you
can hear anything that i'm saying
because i would just sound like this all
the time in the new one we're gonna be
able to tell anything and even then
there's still tiny little
bits of silence between those words
the space
is very similar
how often do you just look at space
itself
right now i'm looking at this
space
and it triggers the profound realization
that that is like the silence between
the notes
draw the analogies like
douglas hofstadter pointed out
analogy is not like
the delaware of the geography of the
united states
analogy is like the interstate highway
system
of the united states take these
analogies
the more child-like the better the more
simple explain like i'm five the better
add them into this conceptual
lattice work of yours as charlie munger
said
the more that you architect that lattice
work from the core disciplines
of the planet science entrepreneurship
spirituality the more you'll gain
compound interest at a younger age and
the more you'll maximize
your potential
and this is the danger of the
neo-advaita
non-dual there's nothing to seek there's
nothing to do
i am already whole and complete
what interest is there then after that
to go and learn from
these core disciplines
entrepreneurship science spirituality
add them into this conceptual lattice
work of understanding
our metaphysical truth and how to
share that with other people
how to eradicate those roots of
suffering like buddha taught
so we'll be unpacking more of that
in our future conversations
we'll never come to the end of
exploration
when you look at
a map
that is bounded
you can come to the end of exploring
that
but when the map is unbounded when it's
limitless
you can never come to the end of
exploring that
there will never be an end to
phenomenology
there will never be an end to the
infinite combinations
of iris that is possible
there will never come to an end of
the layers of identity to add
to these unique expressions
of infinity
and so there will be continued
eternal exploration eternal play
eternal dance eternal
singing eternal creating
and another very childlike friendly way
to think about it
is just like you were at three years old
five years old seven years old 10 years
old combining
the different legos
you can never come to the end of the
combinations of legos
ever that's what this is
you can never come to the end of
possible combinations of legos
it's that simple
how many different possible combinations
of music
endless
how many different possible combinations
of binary
computer science endless
how many even possible combinations of
even the
simple rgb
red green blue colorations on every
pixel on a screen
endless there will never
be an end to all of the different
possible dreamed creation designs
one eternal infinite dreamer you
are that i am that tat
i and my father are one
this is the ultimate this is the
absolute appearing
will never come to the end of
these appearances
and even quantum mechanics in the last
100 years
has very clearly pointed out to us that
all
is no thing
all is energy
modulating appearing
as form and matter
and now the synthesis of science and
spirituality is happening
for thousands of years spirituality has
been saying that and now science is like
as donald hoffman says johnny come
lately
and that's why sir roger penrose who won
the nobel prize in physics in 2020 has a
cyclic cosmology
because nothing else makes sense
what was before the big bang we don't
know what's gonna happen next
we don't know this is just one tiny
finite
thing and that's all that exists ever
that's it
yeah that actually makes a lot less
sense
than eternity than infinity
and this just being one expression of
that that
very clearly makes a lot more
even logical sense let alone
intuitive even logically
it makes a lot more sense eternity and
infinity
infinite songs infinite modulations
infinite energetics infinite worlds
infinite experiences infinite
observers infinite dreams
you are it
this is it
this is the absolute
appearing
endlessly creatively
anarchically
and this creative anarchic
endless appearance
is metaphysical truth
and that's why
the seeking impulse that you have
is the truest thing about you like
bentino massaro said
it is literally the truest thing about
you
the absolute has a
gps callback mechanism
similar to when the dog runs out
and you call for your dog to come back
or
if you fly drones when the drone flies
too far away it has the callback
mechanism
that's the heartbeat of the infinite
that very love outward and dub
inward just like that happens a hundred
thousand times a day
in your own heart
the outward just like in the parable of
the prodigal son
hits the breaking point as the egoic
finite contracted energy
turns inward towards becoming aware
that god is the seer that is eternal and
shared
that's the gps callback that is the
metaphysical truth that we're talking
about this is
just one creation design
the one eternal infinite dreamer
that will never come to the end of
dreaming
that will never come to the end of that
infinitude
sending out these
agents that are unique creative
expressions
into these dreams to undergo the process
of beautifully experiencing and creating
in those dreams and awakening to their
own true nature
like the sufi metaphysic
the unity of all finding all eight
billion right now
just in this creation design undergoing
the process
of satori of sahaja
of nirvana of moksha
of being a bodhisattva of weaving your
profound
realizations like the tantric path into
society it's unbelievable how beautiful
that is
and it takes that seeking impulse that
is the truest thing about you
to pursue hardcore full-time
this is again the danger of neo-advaita
and non-dualism where the
complete eradication of that seeking
impulse
prior to have found infinity
again the fish recognizing that it's in
the ocean recognizing the diamond that's
already around your neck
it still takes the very recognition
itself
and that seeking impulse is the truest
thing about you
to recognize yourself as the one
infinite creator
that then creates the wu way as lao tzu
said that effortless action
going outward
artistically expressing yourself from
the absolute highest morality
and having that child like ah that silly
play
the mouth drums
[Music]
to be able to beatbox
[Music]
to be able to sing whenever you want
and dance and play and
maybe even paint
i love you
to be able to do that artistically
creatively
like a kid whenever you want because you
know you
are that one infinite creator expressing
itself
in this dream
that's why pablo picasso was so adamant
about retaining that
inner child through adulthood look at
all of the corporate zombies
in the economic machine that have no
idea how to be a kid and to play
the kid is just choked out of the
corporate zombies
are our economic markers
around human well-being and prosperity
and abundance
or are they solely in service to
maximizing
shareholder profitability
and that's a whole nother aspect of
polymethy of being a polymath
having learned much across different
disciplines like we talked about with
charlie munger in this conceptual
latticework
that is required to be able to
understand how markets work and how the
economy works
and how to use decentralization
and cryptocurrencies and smart contracts
tokenomics to be able to
share the growing pie more equitably
with everybody you can't
just be spiritual
and especially you can't just say it's
all non-dual there's nothing to seek
done to understand science
to understand entrepreneurship to
understand
all of these mystic traditions and their
unique aphorisms and to learn how to
quiet your own mind
so you don't have the eruptions of anger
and frustration and malevolence
is paramount all of that is paramount
to maximize your own well-being and
happiness your family's well-being and
happiness your friends well-being and
happiness
your partner or spouse your children
the community in the world
this dream relies on
the unique expressions of infinity to
fully turn inward and recognize their
infinitude
not to say there's nothing to do and to
stop
that's what simultaneity means
to recognize that there is
both nothing to do and
that there is already wholeness and that
there
is this veilus veil to pierce
that there is knowledge and liberation
that's
why 2500 years ago the greeks wrote
in the delphic maxim on the top of the
temple of apollo at delphi
know thyself two words know thyself
go all the way inward get to that god
rely state
get to that infinite realized state
and then effortlessly outward
we'll be able to creatively express
ourselves from the absolute highest
morality
one eternal infinite dreamer boom
that was a lot of fun hope it brought
you guys value
thanks so much for tuning in infinite
love to you all
if the video brought you value give it a
like also if you haven't subscribed yet
hit the subscribe button
leave a comment below we'd love to hear
from you share the video
with other people that you feel this
would resonate with deeply
let's create that domino effect that
butterfly effect on planetary awakening
to our true nature that one
eternal infinite dreamer
if you'd like you can join the channel
gain exclusive perks and then also
be able to fuel our unique creative
endeavors that way
that's all infinite love
infinite adoration thank you so much
you are that i am that
we are that asi
i and my father am one we are the
absolute we
are the one infinite creator that's
expressing itself eternally
through these dreamed creation designs
just like we do
when we go to bed at night
super simple child like analogies
share them and awaken
to our true metaphysics thank you
you